Good morning John; it's Monday, January 15th,
and I'm sitting in front of the new Brotherhood
2.0 website which you can find at Brotherhood2.com.
I'd appreciate any suggestions or comments.
The podcast isn't quite working, but we'll
get there.
Well, I'm feeling better. I'm not feeling
great. But now I've got this voice, it's like
not so much of a voice, it's just little popping
noises. Aaaaaahh. One of the advantages is
that I'm kind of a baritone now. I guess I'm
usually a baritone, but maybe I'm a bass?
Maybe I'm a bass now.
(sings) Do not forsake me though you know
I must spend...
So I went to Barnes and Noble yesterday. I
had to walk up to the lady at the desk because
I didn't know where they would keep this book,
and I had to say, "I'm looking for a book,
it's called 'We Wish to Inform You That Tomorrow
We Will Be Killed With Our Families'," and
she said "That's catchy!" So I brought the
book home, and then something interesting
happened.
So yeah, it didn't happen. Um, I'm not saying
that the Brotherhood 2.0 book club is not
a good idea, I'm just saying that right now
I'm going to have to avoid your genocide book
for a little while. And when I say a little
while, I mean, like, less than a week. So
I'll probably start it for Brotherhood 2.0
Friday.
Brotherhood 2.0 Agreement Moment! That's right,
John and I agreed on something! I think it's
a great idea for us to do our happy dances
for three minutes and thirty seconds. That
sounds like a perfect Brotherhood 2.0 project
idea! I don't have Daniel Biss, but I do have
this. It's what the University of Montana
gave me for all of my hard work. 3.5 minutes
times 60 seconds in a minute divided by 5
seconds per clip is 42.
Now there are several amazing things about
this idea:
First, is that you got the math really, very
wrong.
Second remarkable thing about this idea is
that Daniel Biss commented within like, three
seconds of you posting the video and told
you that you were wrong. It must be very convenient
to have your own personal mathematician. I
gotta get me one of those!
Last, and most remarkable about this idea
is that we now know the question.
What are you talking about?
Oh, sorry! Well, the answer to life, the universe,
and everything is 42, right? So the question
must be, "How many happy dance clips does
it take to fill up a Brotherhood 2.0 segment?"
We really are doing some amazing things here.
I've been very impressed by the number and
quality of Misprinted Business Card Utilization
ideas. Thank you very much; I will be discussing
those and other sundrys on Wednesday.
John, I'll see you tomorrow.